قالت امرأة قلتها إنها كانت طبيبة رائعة
في هذا الفيديو الذي أعاد تغريده
الليلة الماضية أن الأقنعة لا تعمل
وهناك علاج لـ covid19 ،
وكلاهما يقول خبراء الصحة إنه ليس
صحيحًا ، لقد صنعت أيضًا مقاطع فيديو تقول إن
الأطباء يصنعون الأدوية باستخدام  الحمض النووي من
الفضائيين وأنهم يحاولون
إنشاء لقاح ليجعلك محصنًا من
أن تصبح متدينًا ، ربما يكون هو نفسه
ربما لا يكون كذلك ، لكن
لا يمكنني أن أخبرك أنها كانت على
الهواء
مع العديد من الأطباء الآخرين ، لقد كانوا
معجبين كبار  من
هيدروكسي كلوروكين وأعتقد أنها
كانت رائعة للغاية
بمعنى أنه من حيث أتت
لا أعرف البلد الذي أتت منه
لكنها قالت إنها حققت
نجاحًا هائلاً مع مئات
المرضى المختلفين وأعتقد أن صوتها كان
صوتًا مهمًا  لكنني لا أعرف شيئًا عنها
الأسبوع الماضي ، شكرًا سريعًا جدًا لكم
جميعًا ،
شكرًا جزيلاً
لكم جميعًا.  itter
على سبيل المثال
لأنهم كانوا يقترحون أنه لا
داعي لارتداء قناع وكانوا يقترحون
أن الهيدروكسي كلوروكين يمكن أن
يقتبس من المحتمل أن يقتبس
علاج فيروس كورونا عندما لا
يوجد دليل على هذا
الذئب ، ليس فقط أنه تمت إزالة الفيديو
من تويتر تمت إزالته من
الفيسبوك وكان كذلك  تمت إزالتها من موقع youtube
للأسف بعد أن تمت مشاهدته
ملايين المرات وذلك
لأنهم قالوا إن هناك معلومات خاطئة في
تلك الفيديوهات التي
رفعها الرئيس وتلك التي كان
يستشهد بها كانت هناك امرأة في الفيديو
تعرّف نفسها على
أنها طبيبة وهي  تقول إن الأقنعة
لا تعمل وتقول إن هناك علاجًا
لـ
covid19 بالطبع شيئان قالهما خبراء الصحة
أنهما غير صحيحين ولذا كنت
أسأل الرئيسة عن أنها
قدمت أيضًا مجموعة من الادعاءات الغريبة الأخرى
بما في ذلك
القول إن العلماء
حاولت ابتكار لقاح يمنعك
من أن تكون أشياء دينية من هذا
القبيل ولذا سألت الرئيس  ما
هو المنطق في رفع منشور كهذا
إلى 84 مليون متابع له
على تويتر وكان يدافع عنه
كان يقول إنها لا تعرف من
أين أتت الدكتورة لكنه كان يتحدث عن
كيف تستشهد بتجربتها الشخصية
مع هيدروكسي كلوروكوين
في المرضى ، لذلك بالطبع نحن لا
نعرف في الواقع كيف تم استخدام ذلك أو
أي شيء من هذا القبيل لهذا السبب
تمت إزالة الفيديو
ولكن بعد ذلك أيضًا من قبل الرئيس
الذي أعاد تغريده أنه يتناقض مع
ما قاله في الأيام السبعة الماضية
وهو  كان يقول إن على الناس
ارتداء أقنعة أنهم يعملون وأنهم
يساعدون في وقف انتشار
covet 19 ولكن بينما كنت أحاول طرح هذا
السؤال استدار الرئيس وغادر
غرفة الإحاطة
، فليس من الواضح سبب إعادة تغريد
شيء ما إذا  لم يكن يريد أن يدافع عن
تغريدة عن ذلك ، لكنه كان مجرد سؤال طرحه
الكثير من الناس
لأنك تعلم أنه يتعارض مع
نصيحة أطبائه وبدلاً من ذلك يرفع
آراءه.  هؤلاء الأشخاص الآخرون الذين ليسوا
أشخاصًا يعملون في
الإدارة لا يعملون على استجابة covet 19
ولذا كان هذا هو السؤال الذي طرحناه
على الرئيس